how much crazier do you think it's going
to get because I think we're we're you
know in the middle of the election cycle
but I I think it's going to get crazier
I agree what do you think is going to
happen because we have the indictments
we have the court hearings but they're
not stopping Trump they're making him
more popular I really do believe we're
we're in an inroad where the system is
becoming more and more desperate how
desperate do you think they will become
well I think they they become more
desperate by the day because I think you
know you look at who they're running on
the Democrat side Joe Biden and
apparently Kamala Harris two of the uh
lowest polling favorability uh I mean
president vice president in history
these two are just absolutely horrible
one worse than the other they have a big
problem on their hands they have no
bench on the Democrat side we seem to
have a little bit of a bench on the
other other side of the aisle but I
think they're getting more desperate by
the day because it must be so
frustrating to see all the effort
they're putting out against one guy and
it's boomeranging back